[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 17 8 culture une
émission pour vous présenter les
initiatives culturelles had dans les
yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui cette année
nous célébrons le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon bonaparte
à cette occasion nous vous faisons
découvrir la collection de la polio nien
du château de versailles louis mortels
chanteur et binoy vient de sortir son
premier single mes yeux dans ton regard
une reprise de l'auteur compositeur
nilda fernandez un avant goût de son
prochain album
et puis nadir youla line sera avec nous
ce soir le producteur originaire de la
verrière nous parlera de jungle jihad un
film préventif autour de la
radicalisation mais aussi de son projet
de film en réalité virtuelle dans les
yvelines et je vous le disais en titre
cette année nous célébrons le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
bonaparte l'empereur est mort le 5 mai
1821 à sainte hélène à cette occasion à
nicolas d'andry est allé découvrir la
collection à napoléonienne du château de
versailles regardez c'est l'une des plus
importantes collections napoléonienne le
château de versailles expose peintures
et sculptures des avoirs représentant
l'empereur les événements de son époque
ses grandes victoires comme celle du
pont d'arcole de marengo ou encore
d'austerlitz mais aussi des
personnalités de son entourage des
offres qui ont toutes été pratiquement
pour l'essentiel commandé par napoléon
pour ces pour sa propre communication et
qui ont été rassemblés ici à versailles
par louis-philippe quand il a créé ces
galeries historique de versailles dans
les années 1830
parmi les oeuvres exposées bonaparte au
pont d'arcole napoléon passant le grand
st bernard ou encore le tableau du sacre
une oeuvre emblématique du premier
empire
réalisé par david c'est un tableau
évidemment qui est une recomposition
d'une scène historique puisque l'artiste
a ouvert le
la scène est finalement sur le devant
que le spectateur participe de l'action
du tableau vraiment on a l'impression
d'être vraiment dans le dans le public
de participer en fait à cet événement du
sacre certains artistes de l'entourage
de david lui ont suggéré de représenter
l'empereur couronnant l'impératrice qui
était une
un geste plus auguste et qu'il y avait
plus de plus de- allure pour le tableau
[Musique]
premier consul stratège général dans les
armées de la république
l'empereur controversé a marqué
l'histoire de france il laisse en
héritage plusieurs institutions un
système administratif en particulier sur
lequel nous vivons encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la structure de l'état français est
complètement un héritage de l'époque de
napoléon avec la création de certaines
institutions comme le conseil d'état la
banque de france la préfecture les
lycées la collection napoléonienne
château de versailles recense 400
tableaux et 200 sculptures
louis mortels chanteur et yvelinois
vient de sortir son premier single une
reprise en attendant son ep qui sortira
lui en septembre prochain
célia gâte son goût bonsoir soir vous
vous avez rencontré l'artiste
oui il vient de serre mais la ville il a
25 ans et son clip est sorti lundi 10
mai regardez les mois seulement
[Musique]
en évitant tout regard
mes yeux dans ton regard cette chanson
des années 90 est une reprise de milda
ferment d'être auteur compositeur
espagnol et français
ce titre parle de rupture amoureuse vous
l'avez dire justin ce single qui vient
de sortir est un avant-goût du nouvel
album qui va bientôt être en préparation
de louis mortels et donc de quoi m'a
parlé ce nouvel album c'est bien eh bien
ce sera sur des thèmes assez varié qui
parle de confiance et d'acceptation de
soi le fait de ne pas vouloir être comme
les autres veulent que je sois etc
je suis comme je suis et on doit
accepter comme ça finalement
c'est un petit peu le combat de beaucoup
de personnes en 2021 sur la question de
soi et de voilà je veux être qui je veux
et c'est tout j'ai pas besoin d'avoir
d'avis de personnes cet album fait donc
écho à cette confiance en lui acquise en
passant par l'émission the voice saison
5 en 2016
il est allé jusqu aux épreuves ultime de
jeudi
quand on voit les gens portent à ton
propre tango mais bon le fragile et
solide
fois ce que j'imaginais soccer je crois
et donc il y aura combien de nouveaux
titres il y aura quatre ou cinq titres
qui seront à son image et à ses goûts
musicaux c'est à dire éclectique
moi j'adore les balades piano voix je
trouve ça je subis mais c'est vraiment
ce que j'adore donc il y aura il y aura
de la balade
mais j'aime aussi le côté pop rock
j'aime aussi le côté un petit peu
variété française donc je pense qu'il y
aura un mélange de tout ça oui donc
rendez vous en septembre pour l'album et
d'ici là son premier single est
disponible sur toutes les plateformes de
téléchargement
merci célia gars tsongo journalistes
pour télé 78 d'avoir été avec nous un
tour du côté du septième art maintenant
avec jungle jihad c est un film
préventif autour de la radicalisation
nadir et hugh lane vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes vous le
réalisateur justement de ce film
indépendant qui est sorti donc en 2020
il a été tourné dans les yvelines
et pendant ce film on suit un peu donc
la course si je puis dire de deux
protagonistes qui semble être un
chauffeur et un client
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus alors merci d'invitation le
climat était qui en 2000 lorsque les
vents dominants ce délai les réalisant
12 avec la attendait de
coproducteur manière indépendante et
l'histoire raconte finalement une quête
entre soi et soi même à travers des
personnages qui sont ancrés dans la
société réelle un chauffeur de taxi mais
en fait ils dans une démarche lui s'est
radicalisée et du coup chauffeur de taxi
est essentielle à mener comme un
chauffeur de taxi et d'estimations qui
serait celi mère ou sa part des actes
terroristes est en fait sur le chemin
s'apercevoir puisque s'il a perdu une
partie de sa famille tanguay
et d atlanta nouvelle partagé par
plusieurs médias parmi les discussions
assez libre parce qu'on d'agir entre les
personnages tout le long du chemin qui
évidemment un film qui tient une
initiative
au final on va il ya toute une métaphore
de la société et des courants de pensée
qui se rencontrent en creux le suivre
cette émission opposition contribution à
favoriser qu'elle à favoriser l'esprit
physique pour avoir un rempart passable
qui serait de du prêt-à-penser on
voulait donner des limites et des moyens
de développer ce sont des fonds propres
roe d'art et de ne pas être forcément
assujettie à prêt-à-penser et ne lui
laissait de contribuer à cette
possibilité là mais ça s'inscrit aussi
dans des longueurs d'onde zhang yang jia
parce qu'il y avait des jeunes lecteurs
de spike lee qui est en même temps dans
l'emploi politiques et initiatives petit
prince sur tout un moment de
transformation de rencontres ça sans
stigmatisation des centres concession
n'évite pas les sujets on n'évite pas
les choses qui pourraient pas on n'est
pas pour aller de son petit peu ce
qu'ils devaient faire mal on va dire
davantage malheureusement dessus mais
aujourd'hui une réelle c'est que tu n'es
pas en réaction ou au drame l'édition
attentats qui tuent en 2015 savant on
sent que récemment
ce que le vilain défend 2010 les défis
sur les rattraper sur moi était une
manière indépendante et avec les
artistes les acteurs et des techniques
internationales nous on peut retrouver
olivier rabourdin
ça arrive larbi et au mien sonne enfin
parce qu'ils se le dire il ya vraiment
différents artistes qui ont contribué à
signer
là vous me disiez ça leur parle de votre
le but c'est un peu de s'interroger
aussi sur la religion peut être
s'interroger sur la société
vous avez voulu aussi peut-être avec ce
film faire de la prévention vous avez
fait peut-être des du visionnage je
n'avais que des acteurs locaux
il a été fait dans une dynamique de
prévention mais c'est pas unique
et c'était là la prévention qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la prévention de
radicalisme elle n'existait pas
institutionnellement elle n'existe pas
moi je les fais à titre personnel et
artistique c'est la glène du film
maintenant le film a la chance
d'intégrer et de participer à des
supports justement des préventions de
débats avec les professionnels mais
également avec une public donc on avait
avec l'éducation nationale dans les
lycées tout ça afin de favoriser le
débat contradictoire échange de points
de vue
le film suit une autopsie une autopsie
du processus dans l'enseignement
comment on sent doctrine petit à petit
c'est pas propre à la religion à la
religion musulmane on pourrait faire ça
avec des capitalistes et un communisme
sont la situation d'entente mais du coup
si sur les processus après effectivement
c'est ancré dans une réalité et avec des
particularismes
mais ça reste une compétition qu'il
parle pourront penser que les qui
traverse les âges qui peuvent disputer
ma qui peuvent me ramener côté côté
sombre de la force d'y participer à tous
et à toutes
et d'ailleurs brièvement je vois que
vous avez un coeur de la cité virtuelle
vous allez prochainement faire un tour
n'a justement dans les yvelines avait en
réalité virtuelle d'un besoin est bien
dit cependant un peu pareil prochain
qu'ils apprennent à lire qui va tourner
en réalité virtuelle en 360
on va tourner un grand parti dans la
partie du bois des temps qui est partie
des origines et du coup c'est un film
qui raconte
la passion pour les courses de 4 cross
les quartiers avec la montée
d'adrénaline dans les premiers jours du
mouvement et tout ce qui tout ce qui
peut se passer
et c'est un team qui vont ouvrir
justement des départs et verte au team
dynamique autour de la réalité virtuelle
de la réalité augmentée les hologrammes
qui est en train de mettre en place sur
st quentin en yvelines avec les sites et
fantastique notamment et sera ensuite
projeté sur le fond les cas ce qu'on
rentre les projections débats en vr et
puis dans le festival
comme tous les films en 360 et à travers
ce film là on propose avec l'association
à ciac petit une démarche des métiers de
l'imagerie numérique appliquée au cinéma
les métiers la réalité et tunnels la
captation 360 la lumière de montage etc
mais appliqué à l'imaginaire et tous ces
métiers qui sont entre les limes et
innovants comme si en réalité ils sont
dans l'air du temps présent donc à toi
qui sera livrée prochainement dans les
yvelines et merci et nadir yens du
joueur très bien et ben c'est noté c'est
noté merci vous tournez région d'avoir
est avec nous un producteur et
réalisateur dans les yvelines
à bientôt et c'est la fin de cette
petite culture merci de nous avoir
suivis à très bientôt sur tb 78 et d'ici
là portez vous bien
[Musique]